Please work,
please work.
Ah, yeah, baby.
Woo, okay.
It seems like it's working.
Oh, my gosh.
It's working.
Yeah, we- Oh.
I can't tell him.
I can't check the audio.
Hopefully it's okay.
I lowered it a little bit.
Oh, my gosh.
Hello, everybody.
Welcome to Lego Indiana.
Jones whoa oh oh we get a little trailer oh wow wow oh the boats wow oh the temple of doom oh my gosh no he's gonna melt his plastic holy wow he's just obliterating these people who the heck was that on the right side i don't remember that guy Whoa, what is that?
Wait, I don't remember this.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, snakes.
Why is it gotta be snakes?
Oh, let's go.
Okay, what's happening?
Oh, yeah.
Use that whip.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, wow.
Oh, my God, is he gonna do it to him, too?
Oh, okay.
Oh, oh, it's that song.
Oh my gosh.
Wow, it's everything.
Wow.
Oh, it's a Lego boulder.
Anything goes.
Ghost made so precious, she belongs in the museum.
Oh, no, it's fighting on the bridge.
Oh, no.
Oh, my gosh.
It's just like the moon.
Lego Gators are so cute.
Oh.
Spoilers.
Okay.
That was the audio, everybody.
I can't tell at all.
I can't check my settings, so.
Oh, dang.
Am I going to be doing that?
It's good?
Okay.
Yay!
Wait, are these all...
Are these, like, the first three movies in...
What?
Wow, what's coming soon?
I sure hope it's...
Comes out soon.
The game is loud?
Okay, I'll lower it a little bit.
It's the first three movies!
Wow!
That's why it's called the original Adventures.
Oh, I honestly thought that...
I didn't know.
Actually, I didn't know if it was going to be based on the movies or like just had references to them.
them or what exciting this is my first time ever playing a lego game that's like based off of an ip so um for those wondering i would like to uh i would like to play like the batman game in the future too and uh you're in for a treat yeah i the only lego game i ever played i was I'm super into Legos.
Like, I loved building Legos, but, um...
Extra kettle!
Uh, but...
What was I gonna say?
Oh!
The only one I played on, like, on my computer was...
Lego Island.
Oh yeah, Lego Star Wars!
I think, though, I need to watch Star Wars first.
Maybe I'll do, like, a watch along or something.
but I'm so I feel you know I love love Indiana Jones so so much I've watched these movies so many times so I figure you know why not start with my best thank you for the super chat I'm so sorry I if I miss what your super chat says I can't I can't get it back it's gone forever no you like my hand thanks Let's just get into it then,
huh?
Are these voice actors?
Oh, hmm.
Hmm.
He's humming.
Oh.
They're just mumbling like the Minecraft villagers?
Ooh.
Icky.
What?
Hmm.
Oh!
He looked so shy!
Where are these boys?
Where did these have boys?
Are they just miming the entire time?
Oh my god, the Lego bats are so cute.
Indy!
No voices?
They just make sounds.
Oh my gosh, we're here!
Wee!
Press Y to take control of other characters.
Oh, oh, yeah.
Kill yourself!
Oh, he's gone?
Oh, he's back.
Yeah!
Oh, oh, yeah!
Look at him go!
He's punching!
Oh, my gosh, I'm collecting.
No, no, no, my money, my money, my money!
Wait, what's this?
Oh, I got like an idle thing.
Wait, okay.
Oh, this is...
Okay, this is...
I like change souls.
It's kind of crazy.
Hiya!
Ha!
Woo!
Sick moves!
Alfred Molina's first rolls.
AKA Dr. Octopus.
What's he doing?
Why is... Oh no, my money!
Oh, okay.
Oh, don't fall off, Indy!
I lost all my money!
Don't do it again.
Okay, this is punch.
Punch, punch, punch, punch.
Wait!
Oh my gosh, could I... Could me and a friend play this?
Look for Lego objects in the ground.
If you have a shovel, press B, dig them up.
Okay.
Whoa!
I don't have a shovel, unfortunately.
But I do have my whip.
Wait, he has a shovel!
Take it out!
Oh, okay, there we go.
Oh, sorry.
There's friendly fire.
How does he have all my money?
Oh, no, just kidding.
I have all my money.
I'm climbing this treehouse.
Nice.
Good job, Indy.
This is so silly.
Okay.
Actually, it actually looks so good even.
Oh, my bad.
Player one's money.
I'm not giving that guy a single penny.
Oh.
Okay, we'll get it.
This is the tutorial.
If I just...
Ah!
Okay, okay.
It's not so cruel.
Huh?
She's learning.
Oh.
Um, he's fine.
He's fine.
Oh!
Why did I jump?
Okay, we're both here.
What is this?
Approach piles of Lego bricks and hold...
What are you to build?
Oh!
I made... What is this?
What is this?
I'm doing archaeology.
Ah!
Yeah!
What does it do now?
Wait.
Oh!
It shoots money!
I'm robbing them blind.
shameless dreams thank you so much for the 10 gift thank you okay infinite money glitch i'm rich baby i'm rich in money and also and also in discovery i just noticed that was a jump thing cool
all right my other friend will be able so if i okay this is not a build what is this sometimes i don't know what i can build and what i can't i feel like everything should be lego i can't i'm kind of taken out of it the fact that the world oh i need the shovel okay friend uh oh he made it nope
player two you can do it
Oh my god, was that a spider?
I think I killed it, though.
Oh my gosh.
With my favorite guy, I thought it was a collab.
Hi, it's Indy.
Wait, is he gonna make it?
Okay, hold on.
Indy, why did you do that?
Alright, now he can make it.
I need him!
I need him to dig that thing up!
Okay, hold on.
Wait a second.
I don't know why I made Indy come- you know what, hold on.
Okay, you go here.
This guy here.
If he jumps...
Oh.
Is he losing our money?
Oh my gosh, no.
It's like Sonic rings.
Maybe use the trampoline.
I don't think the trampoline...
It's all the way over here.
I don't think that's how that works, pal.
I don't think that's how that works.
Wait, hold on.
Let's get our money back.
Use the vine.
I was trying, but he didn't grab on.
I'm gonna get money in?
Okay.
All right.
Grab on.
Okay, here we go.
What could we be buying anyway out here?
Oh.
I'm losing...
I'm losing thousands.
Yeah, that's a harigato.
Why is he not jumping?
Why?
I'm pressing A!
I'm doing this, you guys!
I don't know what's happening!
Oh, wait, that's why.
Right here!
He doesn't jump!
It's not me!
I think it's broke!
It wasn't...
You guys were all blaming me!
Blame!
Blame the VTuber!
Thank you, Supa-chan.
Don't mind, don't mind.
Someone said V-Sync something?
Is it under video settings?
Oh!
Like now?
Oh, okay.
Oh, wait, yeah.
Ah!
We're back!
Oh.
Okay, hold on.
Let's just let's let Indy do it and have this guy just do his own.
Oh, see?
I didn't even need to do anything.
Okay, now dig.
Carry Lego objects to highlighted plates and press B to put them in place.
Oh my money I lost all my money from a bug this sucks it's fine I can punch more plants give me oh wait do you need that you're fine I lost all my money to a bug no way oh wait is this the bad one or the good one Oh, my money, my money.
I need this.
I'm broke.
Wait.
Okay.
Are you the duck that spits money or are you the duck that spits arrows?
You try to beat this level with 10k, 20k studs, buy the first artifact with two players and you'll get 4 billion.
What?
This might still be world record pace.
You're right.
Oh, yeah!
Yeah, oh, oh, oh.
Dig, dig, dig, dig.
Keep digging.
Oh, nice.
My money.
Oh!
Little spider.
Oh, I didn't even notice the spider there.
I love what they all give me.
Money.
Interesting.
Doesn't look that sharp.
When you died and became a ghost, did you drop Lego?
No?
Oh yeah, good job.
Jump over it.
Don't...
He would have... He could have killed me.
For real.
Dig!
Dig, man servant.
Uh, over here.
And B.
What else is here?
What's this thing?
Oh, objects with handles can be pushed and pulled and move up to the handle.
Oh.
So what do I do?
Oh, that's one.
Okay.
Now you.
Ha-ha!
Oh.
I need you to stay where you...
Okay, never mind.
Very good.
Thank you for the gifted friendly elephant.
Oh, oh, we're pressing B.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You need a shovel to paddle vehicles.
We do?
Oh!
That guy's not gonna bother us, is he?
Press A to jump off, or why to switch to another character?
Oh, oh, don't go down the waterfall.
I don't remember this part, everybody.
I don't remember this at all.
Okay, Indy, getting way ahead of yourself, buddy.
I think this guy's...
Oh!
I got greedy.
My bad.
I'm still greedy.
I'm greedy.
Give me money!
Wait!
There's so much to be collected here.
Oh, wait.
Oh, my gosh.
Um, I thought I was supposed to be piloting this thing.
Wait, why am I not piloting it?
Pilot it.
Pilot the boat.
Uh.
Hmm.
Why?
Oh, it's why?
Oh, it is why.
Thank you.
Okay.
All right.
Hi, Andy.
Oh.
Wow, stupid spiders, stupid spiders, just squish them, we squish them.
Oh, we squish them, we squish them.
Okay, nice.
Wow.
It's ASMR, it sounds so good.
Yeah!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Yeah, give me more, give me more!
Indy wouldn't destroy all this stuff.
Woo!
Oh my god!
I'm beating you up.
Oh, oh, sorry.
My bad.
What's over here?
There's more stuff up here.
I'm getting rich.
Oh, there's more.
There's more.
Okay.
We're fine.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Oh!
What's this?
There's more, there's more.
Pull lever.
Pull the lever, crunk.
What did that do?
Can we go inside?
Okay, I'm gonna need you to leave.
Alright, we'll have Indy follow us.
Surely he won't fall.
I don't know why we're so against the wall.
I don't know if that's what I was supposed to- Ah!
Hey, let's go.
I think the shovel is way better.
What's that do?
Oh!
Yeah!
It's called?
Secret tunnel.
Oh my gosh.
Stop it!
Oh.
I'll rescue you in- Oh, you little hat!
Wait, so what is this?
I guess we have to go towards this- Oh, just kidding.
Wait!
Alright.
One sec.
Okay, let's go to the secret tunnel now.
That's priority number one.
We'll do it as Indy.
It's cooler.
No!
Leave us alone!
Okay, the other spider doesn't care.
Oh, yes, he does.
Oh!
Hiya!
Okay.
The boat?
Um, you need to...
You drive the boat.
Oh, we're on it.
We're on the boat.
We're going to pilot the boat.
We're going to drive the boat.
Drive the boat.
I can, right?
Get on the boat.
Okay, and press Y.
There we go.
Thank you, my show.
Yes, yes, yes.
Indy, I'll be right back, okay, buddy?
Oh, I'm too fat.
Wait.
home wait um indie i need a push oh the gator gave me a push
what could it be i wish i could turn the camera i'm scared i'm afraid of falling another lever
okay how mysterious there's so many spiders here What did that do?
Is this not the door?
I thought that would open.
You think if I fall, I'll die?
There's a platform now.
Wait, where?
Oh, I see!
Oh!
Yeah!
Baby!
Oh, I almost missed that, you guys.
Thank you.
The VTuber is blind.
Whoa.
The VTuber has No recollection of...
Anything.
Uh, my friend is dying.
Okay, you get on the boat and you drive.
Okay, nice.
Alright, now we can get out, right?
Okay, good.
Excuse us, excuse us.
So sorry.
Can I...
Eat the alligator.
Treasure, baby, treasure, baby, treasure!
That was close.
Oh, I'm good.
Let's go.
For every spider you kill virtually a real spider shall appear near...
Oh, don't say that.
Okay, what do we got here?
This looks might be modern to be a...
It's like a modern-looking...
What's the word?
Ladder.
Okay, so I need to build something here.
Okay, interesting.
We're in these doing flips and tricks and everything.
Oh.
Wait, if I...
Okay, that's death.
Rain of them.
No!
Alright, so let's go back up here.
Let's...
Because I can't go that direction.
Can I go anything over here?
Anything over...
Death.
Love it.
Losing all my money again.
What do I...
Use Indy.
Oh, I see it!
Where's this?
Oh.
Little spitter.
Um.
They want me to put it on the green.
Ah!
Okay, okay.
Wait, no, pick it up.
Wait, that was wrong.
Like, take it back.
Oh wait, it's gone now.
How'd that work?
Okay.
Now the last one.
Oh, because I'm standing on it!
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Oh my gosh, she's standing on it.
Should we get all on his own?
I didn't have to do anything.
Thank you for playing silly games and having silly time.
Like, really hard day to day.
Aw, happy dog.
Thank you.
We always have silly time.
Don't worry about it.
Oh, right in front of me.
That's embarrassing.
Guys, is this the right time to say I'm not good at platformers?
I'm not good at...
Hmm.
Okay.
Well, you know, um...
Use your whip to pull things that are out of reach.
Oh, okay.
Oh, let's build.
It shows.
What are you talking about?
I haven't even done anything bad yet.
Wait.
Secret.
Okay, get out of my way.
You're gonna fall to your death.
Okay.
We can tell.
Shut up!
You don't know yet.
You don't know anything yet.
You know what?
What if I said I'm God at platformers, huh?
You would be eating your...
Wait, which way do I go?
Let's go to the right first, because it seems like...
Oh!
I see a body!
You see a little... Wait.
You see that little skeleton?
Actually, guys, I lied.
I'm actually God at platformers.
You're all silly for saying that I'm not.
I'm disrespecting his grave.
Alright, actually, let's go the other way.
I might be a little blind.
That's for sure.
Oh my gosh, I made it.
Oh, okay, good.
This was the way.
I want to get up top there.
But it doesn't...
Okay, it doesn't...
Oh, that was close.
A little blind.
I might be a little blind.
I've seen you play Astrobot.
This claim is suspect.
What about me being bad?
I know.
I'm so good.
You're like...
Don't put yourself down, Queen.
Oh!
I should have known.
That was a trap.
Okay.
Well, um, now I know.
Oh, let's see.
Okay.
Oh.
All right.
Okay.
Nice.
We did it.
Okay.
Ouch.
We're fine.
We didn't even get a scratch.
Give me a heart.
Cool.
I had a feeling.
And now open up.
Hi.
What are you doing?
Oh, why are you coming back?
Don't make me do it again.
Oh, I needed...
Oh!
I...
Not a hard dough?
We're fine.
I'm punch.
I'm punching him.
They're just Legos.
It's not even...
Whatever.
They're just...
Oh!
They die in one pot.
Oh, luckily he doesn't.
You need a key to operate this mechanism.
Find one and press B to put it in.
Hey, look behind you!
Oh, is this the key that we need?
Pretty easy.
Okay.
Does it stop or...
Oh, yeah.
No.
Yes.
But... Okay.
But there was some stuff downstairs.
Aha!
Let's go down.
Be careful of Gator.
What am I?
Who's hitting me?
I can't see anything.
Oh, maybe I should have gone down first before I changed the map.
Don't worry about it, everybody.
Don't worry, you're pretty little heads.
Shiny silver Lego objects can be destroyed by blowing them up!
Dunos, all-time favorite Indiana Jones movie.
I like the first one.
Silly Lego things and epic John Williams soundtrack to this good mix.
How to cause explosion.
Hmm.
Oh, oh, never mind.
I saw the spinny purple one and that chat is kind of blocking, but I thought it was a big special one.
It's not.
It's just showing how many coins I have.
Oh my gosh, my thumbnail.
Wait, did we get the sand?
No.
No, don't waste my money.
Not my money!
Oh, okay.
Oh, uh-oh.
Oh, I don't know.
Oh, uh-huh.
Oh, uh, time to go.
Uh-oh.
Time to go.
Oh!
Oops.
You guys know this?
Uh, wait.
I didn't even do anything!
I'm pressing B.
Oh, maybe I have to...
Okay, I just jumped to this.
one.
No, I don't.
Please!
Andy!
Good thing we're in no rush, right, everybody?
I'm a pro gamer!
Here I go!
Oh, oh, oh!
See?
Gosh, you guys.
Come on!
Uh-oh.
Okay.
We're going.
That gold piece will just have to I have to wait.
Hoi!
There's more over here.
It's fine.
Oh!
We'll let it go.
We're in no real danger.
I don't know how he survived, though.
Wait, can I beat this thing up?
Only thuggy characters know the secret way to activate.
Oh, what?
Is there, like, New Game Plus in this?
Oh, gosh.
That scared me.
Okay.
Oh!
Oh, that's so unfair.
I didn't see it coming.
Okay.
Jump!
Okay, that's so unfair.
Okay, you get the other one.
Yeah!
Good job.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, we needed to!
There we go!
Okay, nice.
All right, let's keep going.
Ah!
It's so...
Oh, I made it somehow.
Oh my gosh, we're not fine.
What?
We're fine.
Oh my gosh.
I need to adjust my controller.
Okay, there we go.
I'm fine.
Oh, I'm not fine.
No, I have to do it for the very beginning.
That's so lame.
Oh.
Oh, wait.
Oh my gosh.
I'm just keep having to adjust my controller.
Wait!
Please!
Wait.
Alright, we gotta be- We gotta be perfect.
Oh.
We're fine.
It's like only right behind us.
Don't worry about it.
The tree is right behind me.
Isn't she?
Oh, see, I made it!
He double-crossed me!
Wait.
Oh, you want a rubber ducky?
What is happening?
What?
What is going on?
Why is he a robot all of a sudden?
Is it because he's the C3PO?
Ah, we almost gave him the other golden head.
Ha ha ha!
Wait, when did short round get here?
Hello?
I beat up plants, I beat up plants.
Look how cool I am.
I'm an adult and I beat up.
Ah!
Oh my gosh, there's people.
I beat up people.
I actually kill people.
And I take their stuff.
What is this?
I took that crossbow.
I beat it up.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
I just killed a child.
We're fine.
Anyway, we'll escape once I have a true adventurer.
What does that mean?
We, we, we, we, it's just...
Do you have to do it?
Oh, you're beating me?
Oh, you're not sure why you're the pilot.
I don't know anything that's going on, you guys.
I'm like, why is he here?
Hey, hey,
come here.
Take, take, take, take.
All right, yeah, beat him up for me.
I put this together.
Oh, just kidding.
Oh, my gosh.
I can't believe it.
Okay, the whip is kind of bad.
Oh, my gosh.
So awesome.
Oh, sorry.
Oh.
I'm not... I'm not trying, I promise!
Oh my god.
Oh, there's a thing here.
Bravo?
Okay.
Does it want me to jump over there?
Oh my gosh, there's stuff all the way over there!
Okay, finally it's letting me...
Oh, I think I can't build until I'm...
Until I kill all the guys.
That's why I wouldn't let me build before.
Maybe.
Okay.
Sorry.
Even his hair!
Okay, keep going, keep going.
Keep going, keep going.
Yeah!
Woo!
Oh.
Oh wait, I can swim?
There's no crocodiles, so...
I wonder what he's doing.
Well, I'm getting rich in the water.
I guess I didn't think about it because the crocodiles were in there before.
Getting rich over here.
Awesome.
Ha!
Oh, ha!
Wait, hold on.
And, oh, ha!
And, ha!
Nah, I can't.
All right.
Oh, my gosh.
Kick your butts!
I'll kick your butts!
Yeah, drop kick!
Okay, go fix it.
Fix it.
Fix.
Fix the machinery.
Do it!
Oh, yeah!
He can really hold his own, huh?
Oh, my
gosh.
Oh, my gosh.
Is the snake violating?
Oh, no.
A free play!
I can be Indiana Jones or I could be...
Satipa!
Or Jock!
I'm a true adventurer, everybody.
Wow.
That was a sound.
Oh,
my cow!
It just keeps going!
I missed four.
That's kind of crazy.
Well, I guess there were some things we couldn't...
We couldn't get to.
Barnett College.
What's here?
Oh, save?
Oh, that's the hub!
Oh, so we're going in?
You can't get all the pieces of a treasure on the first playthrough.
Okay, that makes sense.
Oh, yeah, I've got my...
Oh, I am the pilot.
I've got my pilot here.
It's me.
I'm the pilot.
Dang.
I hope the school doesn't make me pay for those.
Can I kill this too?
Oh, no.
Oh, dang it.
mission.
Hello.
She's too fast for me.
Who are you?
Get her.
I was.
Oh.
Someone said that I should buy things.
Do I buy things in here?
Is this the buying things area?
Don't take my money.
I did whip that woman and I do it again.
I saw it in the trailer.
Watch, I can whip her.
And then she comes to me and I give her a big old smooch.
Oh, cute.
Oh, fun.
Oh, I wonder what it looks like completed.
Buy pieces.
No.
I'm going to collect them myself.
What's this?
Oh!
Give me the money!
Why do we have such a discovery in our own museum?
Just buy it?
No!
I know I'm rich, but...
Hmm.
I love how all these people are looking at empty exhibits.
Nobody's looking at the one thing that actually has something.
This music gets emotional.
Does it?
Are you feeling a little emotional by it?
Oh.
Courtyard!
Is there gotcha?
I think this was before gotcha was so it was popularized.
So we're safe from gotcha here hello why can't i hmm interesting
oh oh i can oh how
what are you do you get in there too
metal gear oh whoops
Gosh, everything explodes.
Just a bush.
Don't worry about it.
And we're getting rich here too by doing vandalism.
What is this teaching the children?
Why does it have to be solid sake?
That's so good.
Oh, wow!
The art...
Stranger.
You're no stranger to me.
What's this?
Oh.
Oh, my god!
What?
Mint!
Can he be blue?
No, dang.
Mint!
Oh!
Close, close, close enough.
Can they even change his tiny whites?
There we go.
What does this do?
It just tells me things and does not give me any explanation.
Power, thank you!
Thank you so much for the hook, Asupa.
I hope you have a great rest of your week.
You too!
What should we wear?
I should like be Lego hair.
Wait, did they have white hair?
No.
Close.
Hey, what are you doing here?
Oh, good.
I can kill him.
And then take his shovel.
Yeah, murder in the museum!
Wait, I really just...
just... Oh, he's following me.
Oh, his ghost.
His ghost is now haunting.
Okay, what's on the other side?
What is this?
Should I just buy it?
It's characters.
Oh!
Well, they don't even ask.
Like, are you sure?
You just have it.
Oh my gosh, I can destroy everything in here, too.
Crazy.
I wish there was, like, a roll.
I feel like...
I wish I could...
Go a little fast sometimes.
Yeah!
Destroy everything!
We hate books!
Nice.
Getting my money.
Oh!
Hello.
Welcome, I just, uh...
I just invited you to my home.
I love destroying everything.
Even though Legos is about creating, they're just like, no.
Break it off.
There was rare manga in that stack.
Sorry, buddy, it's gotta go.
Oh, even the table!
Yeah!
Damn!
So destructive!
Now we Lego-ing!
Yeah, baby!
Did I make all my money back yet?
I don't think so.
That's okay.
I bought this guy and I don't know what he does.
Why I have him.
Thanks for the cafe recommendation.
It gives me an excuse to go back and waste money on the Hollow Life Street Fighter Collab Creek.
You're so welcome.
What's in here?
More money and things to destroy.
It belongs in a museum.
It belongs in a landfill!
Secret characters.
Fertilizer.
Silhouettes.
Ice rake?
Are these like additions to...
To the school?
What kind of extras are these?
I kind of want the ice rink.
Those are cheats you can enable.
Buy the secret characters.
It's kind of pricey.
Any bitchhead run?
There are extras you can turn on and like...
Oh!
Well, hold on.
I still want to see what else is going on here.
There's the main hall.
Wait, why are these shiny?
Hey, hey, why are you walking around like that?
Don't be so aggressive.
What?
Who's camping?
Oh, my bad.
Oh, sorry.
Secret character unlocked Solid Snake.
Don't lie to me.
Do we
just stuck out?
Oh this looks like a movie.
How cute!
Oh it just plays this again.
Okay, wait, how do I get out?
Wait, oh gosh.
Wait, no wait.
Oh no, no, no, no.
Oh my gosh, no!
I can't, everyone let me out!
Okay, I'm mashing literally everything on my controller.
Okay, while it does this, I'm going to get some water.
You guys can watch.
I'm gonna get water and you guys can watch.
Hmm?
.
Okay, I'm back.
Sorry about that.
Let's play more game.
How do I get back to playing more game, though?
Everybody else left the theater.
So sad.
Do I leave?
I like that.
I guess in the future, we get to sneak around a little bit.
I'm excited for that.
Welcome back.
Thank you.
I'm so sorry about that.
Oh, here we go.
I see it.
I see the maps.
Oh, oh my gosh.
I can't stop.
Okay.
I gotta stop collecting money.
Temple of Doom!
Wait.
Oh.
Wait, I can do...
Oh, wait.
Now we have to do this one.
We're already in the middle of it.
Okay.
Lost Temple and then we are going here into the mountains.
Well, let me do free play so we're doing story.
Who the hell is a mummy walking around?
Oh, oh.
Oh.
Is this actually Harrison Ford?
It's like Charlie Brown when the adults are talking to the kids.
You need to watch the movies.
No.
I understand everything right now.
I've never watched a single Indiana Jones movie.
It's a...
Sleepy.
Oh, what a devilish little guy.
Oh, oh.
Oh, I like it.
Oh, what?
No, I was looking at your necklace.
My goodness.
Okay, now let's rob her blind and destroy her store.
Her bar.
Are there other guys that are supposed to be destroying her bar, though?
What does this do?
Oh.
Oh, wow!
Ladies are more nimble and can jump higher than other characters.
Ooh, la-la.
Oh, we're just really destroying everything.
We're destroying actually everything.
Is this true?
I'm very nervous.
It's technically true you haven't watched a single Indiana Jones movie.
Wait, I don't get it.
Guys, it was a joke.
Of course I've watched Indiana Jones.
It's like my favorite movie series.
Love Indiana Jones.
This is so silly.
She doesn't mind that I'm like...
Literally Destroying her bar Let's see how high she can jump How high can he jump?
Oh wow, wimpy Wimpy, wimpy Wimpy man Yeah Yeah I feel like they left some things out of the cutscenes You know, I feel like A few things have been you know left out a little bit how do I get behind there wait how do I get behind
there just a bit like the reason her bar is on fire you know like that kind of stuff maybe on the second floor that's what I was thinking oh what's this oh Oh, it's so fun!
Oh, my depth perception strikes again, everybody.
Don't mind me.
Wait, what's this one doing?
Ah!
Nice.
There's so much stuff here.
So much going on.
Okay, I'm gonna build this and then I'm gonna destroy it.
That's the true Lego way.
Stop by and say hi.
Hello.
Minto time.
What?
What are we doing here?
Okay.
Not quite sure yet.
Can I go through here?
No.
I want to go to the second story.
Ah, I see.
I see here.
I'm a nimble lady.
Nimble lady.
Oh.
Oh, I see now.
Aha!
Go up, go up, go up.
She hates her.
She hates this place too.
She's destroying everything also.
Alright.
Destroy!
Does
this...
Oh, wait.
Press it!
Pull it!
Ahah!
Oh!
Pop it!
Squeeze it!
Anything else in here?
No?
Okay.
No puzzle is too difficult for me!
Wait.
Let's get more cash money, baby.
This game time- Oh, there he is!
Hello.
Oh.
Yeah!
Pressing B.
Throw Lego objects.
Oh!
I'm gonna throw a Lego object at you.
Don't mess with me.
You'll get a Lego object at you.
You'll get a Lego object throwing at you.
Otherwise, where's her necklace?
Oh, I needed that heart.
Oh, there he is.
I'm gonna throw this Lego object at you!
I'm gonna throw this.
Wait.
Yeah!
Indy does a great job at knocking them out.
Boss with the machine gun appears.
Throw objects at him, okay?
Stop coming.
Oh, get him now.
Oh, wait.
Dang it.
Oops.
Wrong button.
No!
I'm trying to throw objects at you!
Oh, there he is.
Wait.
Dang it!
I locked onto the wrong thing as soon as I...
pressed V.
Is this a boss?
This is what it is.
It's so funny.
Oh, we got him.
No, the necklace!
Oh!
The boss with the machine gun!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
I need heart.
Thank you.
Oh, uh, jump down, please.
Oh, my god.
Give me a heart.
Thank you.
Ah!
We took him down easy peasy, no trouble at all.
Wait, grab the gun.
Grab the gun.
This is huge.
Oh, God.
What's that smell?
Yeah, your ass is grass.
Maybe she did like this place.
Oh.
Oh, there's more people?
Oh, I was just shooting, shooting.
Oh, wait, I can just...
Oh.
Wait, my gun!
What happened to it?
Oh, you have a gun, too.
I'll take that.
Yoink.
Okay.
You think I can shoot this?
Find a way to cause an explosion.
Wait, no.
Oh.
Wait, but there's a little laver.
What is that, actually?
I don't know what that is.
Use the torch.
Oh, my gosh, you can really just grab whatever.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, hey.
Hey.
I like how I'm not even playing as Indy.
I'm like...
What am I...
What am I building?
Why is it... Oh, am I building a snowman?
We have priorities.
I don't stop coming, I don't stop coming.
The... ow!
I'm getting shot at!
Indy!
Indy, I'm gonna die!
Oh, I died, Indy.
I died.
Let me grab my money.
Oh, yay!
Give me my money!
Oh, I lost it!
Indy, don't just take the shot.
Putting this over here.
There we go.
And then grab this.
And fix, fix, fix, fix, fix.
My money.
Okay.
Was there anything else?
I'm sure there is.
Oh, yeah.
Another explosion.
Wait, so I could go inside someone's house?
Oh, there's a golden thing in there!
Hey, quit shooting me!
Ow, it should!
Oh my gosh!
Quit shooting me!
Gosh!
Wait, why am I not even hitting?
Let's get my own gun.
Grab my own gun.
Please, grab it.
No, that's not what I wanted to do.
Oh, what's this?
Is this another snowman?
Priorities?
Wait, can I hide behind this?
Why are they in the ground?
Oh, so am I!
Okay, nice.
Oh, not nice.
Oh, good, good, good.
This is good.
All right, cool.
Ooh, who's that?
What is this?
Is this a shovel thing that we need?
Shiny in the snow, yeah.
I can't get it.
I can jump on the animal!
Indy, you handle them.
Oh my god.
Lego alpacas.
They're so cute!
Okay.
Can we go in here?
No, but what do we do with this?
Fool guards by wearing the right hat.
Oh,
I see their hat.
Mr. That was not very kind.
What is this, anyway?
What is this?
Oh, it's a gun, I think.
I need a hat.
Please, sir.
All right.
We'll wait for them.
And we'll get their hat.
I don't know what this is.
It won't let me.
Let me get it.
Oh, no.
Drop your hat!
Can I take this?
No.
Wait, is this a hat?
Use the torch to melt the snow.
Oh, let's try.
Oh.
I don't think you can...
Oh, sorry.
Oh, wait.
I'm pressing V.
Oh, let me pick it up.
Whatever it is.
Oh, I got it.
Okay.
I don't think this is a hat, though.
I'm not sure what it is.
Oh, well.
Let's just keep going.
These guys are so annoying.
They don't let you explore for any amount of time.
I'm going.
Oh.
So was he?
Wait, we're all going?
Wait.
Why are we all going?
Oh.
I'm trying to get down.
Why?
There we go.
Thank you.
Okay.
Um.
What's going on?
You made me lose my body.
All right.
Oh, Indy.
Indy, it's your turn.
No, don't do that.
No.
Ah!
I'm not trying.
It's pushing me away.
I think I need to do it from here.
There we go.
Okay.
I understand.
I'm learning the game still, everybody.
Hello?
It would be really great if you fought!
Indiana Jones!
Oh my gosh.
I'm punching, I'm punching.
Okay, they're dead.
We're fine.
We can push Lego objects on the tile floors.
Okay, we're fine.
Everything's good.
Everything's fine.
I need her.
Also, I need another torch.
I'm coming back.
Coming back.
Alright, give me that.
Alright, now.
Go back.
Alright.
Where's the torch?
Okay, there we go.
We're fine?
Oh, give me that.
Okay.
Here.
Yeah.
I'm not sure why it's not...
Oh, there we is.
Could have used the fuse.
The fuse that I definitely didn't miss.
Yeah.
A fuse that I completely saw.
That fuse.
Classic Minkeana Jones.
What can I say?
Wait, hold on.
Alright, push.
Push.
Watch out, Indy!
Oh, just kidding.
How do we get this one though?
Where'd the torch go?
Minkiana.
All right, take this.
Run, run, run, run, run, run.
Throw.
Just kidding.
Grab.
Throw.
Wait.
Take it out.
Throw.
Oh.
Oh, it needs more!
I see.
Alright.
Wait, where'd my torch go?
I'll have to go get another one.
Okay.
And then we'll blow it up.
We'll blow it all the hell!
Run!
Yahoo!
Oh, only small characters can fit through hatches.
Like a mouse?
Which movie is this?
Um, the...
All of them.
What's going on here?
What we got?
Ah!
Oh, I hate that we drop money sometimes.
Oh, but she's not even picking it up!
Ma'am!
Okay.
Wait, why aren't you... Why am I not picking it up?
I'm on the first movie.
I'm on all of them.
Wait!
I guess I have to jump for it, huh?
But like, each time?
Okay.
Cool.
No, we're going on this side, lady.
Okay.
I see, I see.
Uh-huh.
Alright.
Jump.
Yes.
What is this thing?
You gotta jump.
Ah, you should just be able to get it from just walking over it.
I think.
Alright, let's go get this.
What is this anyway?
Aha.
Oh-ho-ho.
I don't remember this part being so long in the movie.
You know?
Wait, where does this go?
Oh, this continues onwards.
No, no, no, not yet.
Wait.
Am I dumb?
How do I get up there?
I'm back from Silk Song with the promised milk in Gamer's hand.
How's it going?
We're going.
Okay.
Okay, hold on.
Maybe I...
Hoi!
No?
Oh!
Just use your use your little Lego hands!
And hoi!
Hoi!
Oh!
I don't know why I can make it up here.
We're gaming.
Okay.
Yippee!
It wasn't even that much.
You can double jump.
Oh, like the thing that I'm trying to do, that like, if I press A again, it doesn't work.
That thing that you say I can do, but literally when I try, it doesn't do that.
What the?
Oh my god, where'd you guys come from?
Um, Indy, I need you to finish- oh.
Oh my god!
Why didn't you finish him off?
Taking this big guy.
I wonder.
Oh, Indy can only, like, dive.
It's not even a double jump.
It's a double- what is it?
He's like, he's doing something.
Where does this go?
Oh, here.
Okay.
Oh, it's the platform, that's why.
What's happening?
Oh!
It's fine, we're gamers.
Oh my gosh.
Uh-huh.
Okay.
We're fine.
Everything's okay.
Maybe.
Oh, oh.
There's stuff here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh!
Wait, hold on.
Swing!
He is dodge rolling souls type.
Who's in there, by the way?
There's like someone freezing in there.
Okay.
Maybe?
Just a little bit.
Just a little bit of...
Oh!
I made it!
Oh, wait, it's sealed or something.
Wait.
Oh my god!
They're amongst the skellies!
So cute!
She doesn't know...
I don't know which way I'm supposed to go.
No, no, no.
Not yet.
Let's go see the person first.
Okay.
We'll go down.
We're going down, bam!
It's a Star Wars reference.
Oh, is it actually?
No wonder I wouldn't get it.
Wait!
I'll get you out of there!
Oh, I actually can't go in.
Wait, that's a Star Wars guy?
Got a torch.
Okay.
We can do that.
Well, torch actually work, though.
I guess we'll find out.
Is there one over here?
Maybe in here?
I like the little children's playset that we have going on here.
Okay.
Wow!
Woo!
Wait, can she jump up there?
Good job!
Oh, wait.
She could get this.
I know she can.
Um...
Okay, there's a lot going on here.
Let's see.
This...
Oh, gives us the shovel!
Okay.
You take the shovel.
Minkiana Jones.
Star Wars original trilogy watch- I know, I need to watch them.
Oops.
Go in.
And that's why I couldn't grab it before.
Oh, oops.
There we go.
Oi!
Nice.
I'm a platform gamer, everybody!
Which way do I need to push it to, though?
Doesn't matter.
It looks so heavy, but it is actually so light.
Hmm.
Wait, maybe we push it to this side so that she can jump?
Is it a platform?
Oh, wait.
Oh, it is a platform for something.
I'm...
Orange Lego Place can be activated with extra weight.
I see.
Looks like Mothman.
Glad he's frozen in there and we're out here.
And he is the Star Wars.
And that we are frozen out there.
We're in here.
And I just remembered we're out there.
Thank you, Fred.
Oh, wait.
I think I get it.
Okay, okay, okay.
Um, okay, hold on.
I need to go back up here, and somebody stands on it.
AKA, her.
And then, Indy pushes it.
No.
No!
Oh, gosh, but wait!
They follow each other.
Um.
Oh, wait.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Yes, I know.
Oh!
The AI is good.
The AI worked.
Okay.
All right.
We're building.
Aha!
No, no, the money!
The money!
No, grab the money!
Grab the money!
Anyway, okay.
Onwards?
Onwards and upwards?
My money!
I am greedy.
I'm greedy.
I want it all.
Oh, wait.
Here's a torch.
Okay, now we can...
Oh, what's this?
We can grab...
True adventurer!
We can grab this and go.
back to oops back wait, do I still have it?
okay, I do okay okay ma'am excuse me okay, back to Star Wars land
okay, okay Star Wars Star Wars, Star Wars Star Wars Okay.
Okay, back, back, back.
Nice grab.
Wait, my toe!
No!
I dropped it!
When did I drop it?
It ran out.
Wait, does it actually run out?
Is it, like, a timed thing?
It has a time limit.
I wonder.
if going this way would be better.
Maybe there's one over here instead.
Let's see.
Uh.
This also feels really far.
This is also really far.
No, there's no way.
Oh, man.
There's nothing here, but What is this light then, huh?
Gotta go fast.
Like the fastest.
But I also want the treasure chest here.
I think I need...
I'm actually not sure, but I think I need to defrost that too.
I would recommend watching the first six movies in this order.
I think I'll watch and release.
Guys, I think I give up.
I think I give up on saving that guy.
He can rot in hell.
And what's this?
You need a book to translate mysterious hieroglyphs.
I am Indiana Jones.
I need a book?
The book is my brain.
Too fast, too minky.
Oh, apples.
Mm-hmm.
Oh, what's this?
What is this?
Um, it is for...
Uh...
Oh, I thought that was a dog.
It's for...
The...
Truck.
Yes.
Oh.
Oh, I'm greedy.
Oh!
Okay.
What is it?
What are you?
Why are you shining?
Okay, let's look around some more.
Let's look around a bit.
Yes!
One moment, please.
What's this?
The thing I can destroy?
No!
Yeah, I can destroy this.
Silver items go boom.
That's right.
They go boom.
You think player two is ever gonna start the game?
Lazy?
What's this?
Hmm.
I'm doing, I'm pulling all the work here.
My controller isn't working?
Yeah, likely excuse.
You just know that I'm so good at the game.
You would be embarrassed.
Come on, it's just Legos.
You can do it.
They're just Legos.
Wait, there is a purple one over there.
Oh, all right, lady.
I can't remember her name.
I feel terrible.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, I didn't even see this.
Hello?
Move?
Nice.
Ooh, big money!
Marion.
Yes, Marion.
Thank you.
I'm so bad with names, everybody.
I think you guys know this by now, though.
If you know me, you might know that I'm not very good with names.
It's a character flaw.
Ah,
no, you can't jump.
Wait, jump, jump.
Yeah, baby.
We know, Dennis.
Okay.
What do I do with...
What is this?
I can't even tell.
I think it goes to the top.
truck let's
see okay two people doesn't do anything else hmm maybe the alpaca is heavy enough ah can you do it again thank you no no no what is this I want the is Is this a bigger gun?
Oh, sorry.
There we go.
Oh, yeah, we got a bigger gun.
Oh, wait, this is an exploding gun?
Okay, wait.
Oh, come on.
Wait, really?
Well, maybe this blows up this thing over here, then.
Yes.
Yes!
You can operate spinners by pushing against the green and red paddles.
Oh, how cute!
Oh.
Wait, who are you?
Ah!
Take their guns?
More!
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Alright, we gotta do this like fast then, huh?
What is this?
Can you take it, please?
Oh, it's another one.
Why are you giving this to me?
The llama is so annoying.
Oh, it's just working on its own now.
We...
Oh no, I lost my wrench though.
Oh wait, Indy has it.
Indy.
Oh, he's...
Okay, wait, she's...
Ah!
I blew up.
Don't mind me.
My money, my money!
Okay.
All right.
Indy, Indy, come here.
Right.
Indy, come here.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Indy, come here.
All right.
Fix this.
Everyone died.
We bazookaed everybody in the face.
Now what?
Ah!
Stop.
Heading me.
Who are you people?
What was the point of this?
Actually, I'm not quite sure.
What is this thing?
Do you know?
Is this a crank?
Wait, there's a...
Hmm.
That wasn't paying attention, guys.
My money, my money, my money, my money!
Look at they got little smiles on their faces.
Take it.
Wait, is this the... Does this go to that over there?
Okay, Marion, I'm gonna need you to cover me, okay?
Marion, cover me.
Yeah, yeah.
Marion, take care of them.
Marion, do it.
Yeah, yeah.
Cover me.
Can't cover me!
Various!
Cover me!
Ah!
I died again!
I lose all my body!
It wasn't even what I needed.
It was a bonus.
Okay, let's get on the...
Let's get on this guy.
Artifact again.
Well, I actually don't think this guy is any much faster than...
What exploded?
Oh, sorry, Indy.
Can we just get in the car now?
Can we leave?
Can we...
Wait, I'm actually...
I don't know what to do.
I thought we got in the truck and left.
Oh, the truck is silver!
Ah!
I see, I see.
Grab.
Oh, thank you.
And bazooka!
Bazooka!
Me too.
Wait, do I bazooka it again?
Oh, take it and...
Bazooka!
Yes!
Oh, there we go, there we go!
It's on fire!
Bazooka!
Oh, I keep getting myself too!
We're fine.
Maybe.
Actually me.
Why is there splashback in this children's Indiana Jones game?
Now we just have 50k.
I know!
Oh, yay!
Marion.
Okay, I think I got my money back.
God, the sound is terrifying.
Okay, just kidding.
We have, like, way money.
I'm going to go unlock everything.
Wait, let's go unlock everything.
The sound is so broken.
It's, like, does it all at once?
So it's just crazy loud.
Just prrr.
Okay.
What is this?
This is math?
Oh, classroom.
How do I activate it?
How do I put in a cheat code?
No?
Oh, there we go.
8008.
Okay, you're so right.
But you could just put the letters.
This is more fun this way.
Oh, sorry, everybody.
You are not learning today.
Not on my watch.
No seats allowed.
No sitting allowed.
No living either.
Okay, anyway.
I don't think I went into there before.
This was...
What room?
Here we go.
Oh, wait.
There's so much...
Bazooka trooper.
Wait, there's actually...
Wait.
Oh, this is just buying the characters.
Do we want to buy more characters or do we want to buy more cheats?
They are expensive.
I know that's why I don't want to lose money.
Was it this room?
Yes.
Secret characters.
Disguises.
Fertilizers.
or...
Silhouettes.
Beep beep!
Ice rank!
Yeah, I've got everything!
Beep beep!
I don't know what it does, but...
we got it.
Turn them on in the pause menu.
Like extras?
On.
Adaptive difficulty.
This guy on.
On.
Oh.
Wait that.
Stop.
around all right let's keep playing next chapter city of danger this is so cute oh
oh we're gonna meet best guy wait who are these people
they actually look like they're disguised Like, it actually works.
Not even the monkey!
Oh,
it's so silly.
It's okay, that monkey's gonna die later.
Guys, he's bad, it's fine.
He's a bad guy.
Oh, throw a banana.
Okay.
Give me that.
Oh, okay.
Jeez, it's violent.
So violent.
The bad dates, yeah.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
Oh, no, I didn't know that.
Being violent actually had consequences.
I'm sorry.
Sorry, I'm a good fellow.
Please.
Please believe me.
I'm good, I'm good.
Believe me, believe me.
I'm getting my ass handed to me.
Um, what's this?
Oh, we need to fix it.
You think they'll be...
They hate me for now on forever?
That would be really sad, huh?
Actions have consequences.
I just like to beat stuff up.
I just like to beat...
to punch everything.
Okay.
We're good now.
We're good.
We're chill.
Oh, no, we're not chill.
We're not chill.
This guy has a sword and is coming at me!
I'll take that.
Give me the sword.
Yeah.
Yeah!
Is this because I did, I messed up?
Or...
Are they mad at me?
Oh, we can build apples.
Can I have that back?
Can I have your sword back, please?
Oh, wait.
I'll take this, too.
This also works.
I killed!
Use the banana.
Throw the banana at them.
So true.
Wait, is this not a digging spot?
Oh, yes, it is.
We're building.
we're fast have you guys ever watched like professional lego builders they're actually so insane no no i'm fine
what's over here i'm rebuilding things i'm i'm i'm being a good asset to this world
okay nice nice nice huh yes See, they're going to be, they're all going to love me.
I'm a master builder.
Wait, are you actually?
Those guys are crazy.
That's in here.
Oh,
what do I do?
Or is she?
Is it because you're so nimble?
More people!
What did I do?
Oh.
No, we're fine.
The music's up.
Everything explodes.
Oh, hello.
I am friend?
Oh, shoot.
I'm a friend!
I need a small character, like a monkey.
Like a little tiny monkey to fit through.
Please!
Oh.
what can I do with this throw it at the monkey no wait what is it here what is it wanting me to do this oh wait I just I just built this am I am I building it to destroy it maybe I am a menace to the society maybe they will hate me they're Like, oh my god,
wait, maybe I'm building this, like, false trust.
I had a...
I had one, right?
A, uh...
A wrench?
Oh, no, he gave me a shovel, that's right.
There's so much around here.
Yeah, destroy, explode.
Destroy, explode.
You can... Oh!
Walk up and press... No, I don't have the right hat!
He's gonna blow me up!
Uh-oh.
Can I have your sword?
I want that... Oh!
Yippee!
I'm pushing.
Okay.
Now you.
Music is dramatic for no reason.
They're just watching me.
try it i have a disguise i don't think that's how these disguises work are they wait oh oops my bad okay oh so close oh my gosh why didn't i do it the first time okay there we go
stupid lady all right i'll try it i'll try it with the disguise but i don't have the right hat on Oh, hello.
Where'd you guys come from?
I don't have your hat.
What is this?
Oh, it's a sword.
Alright, here we go.
Let's try.
That then.
Hello.
Hi.
No?
Oh, we're back to normal now.
Everything's fine.
No hat.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, so close.
Okay.
I guess I could have just jumped on this, huh?
Dude, I was, like, making it more difficult for myself.
Grab, grab it.
Grab the money.
Whatever you do, Marion, grab the money.
If everyone's in disguise, no one is.
You're right.
How do I get a hat though?
Okay, but first, hold on.
There's some other things I want to do over here.
Oh wait, we need another...
Wait, what's in here?
Uh, oh.
Don't kill me!
There's a lot going on over here.
Game says I'm about to die.
Oh.
Okay.
Thanks for doing that.
They're like, hey, do you want to throw away your sword and, like, not use it anymore?
Shirley.
Wait.
Give me that.
Thank you.
Oh, this is a digging spot.
I'm dumb.
Okay, now pull.
No, pull.
This is a pulley, you know?
You pull it.
Pull it.
Oh my goodness!
She did the thing!
Wait, am I dumb?
I know, I mean, I am, but like, also...
Impedious.
Why is it not working?
What's going on?
Indie you, beast?
Jump from the stairs.
Like here?
Oh, a monkey.
I thought this was a lever, though.
It's not.
What was the point of attaching it?
You can break this fence.
Ah!
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
Okay, now...
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm learning how this world works.
Slowly but surely.
Oh, hello.
I'm learning how this world works.
What's in here?
Why is it like that?
Oops.
Break everything.
Yeah, oh my gosh.
They're not kidding.
Oh, look.
Okay, and then this is the other piece that we needed.
Oops.
Just kidding.
There we go.
Oh, dang it.
Sometimes she bounces high and sometimes...
Not at all.
Okay.
How do I get in there?
Oh, nice.
It's not...
Let's go.
Come on, Mary!
Ah, there we go.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Um, there's even more, maybe?
Oops, okay.
We'll make it, we'll make it.
Welcome to Lego World.
I'm learning!
Oh.
Depth perception is a skill.
I don't think I actually need to...
I think I'll...
I have to do is hold it.
Yeah, I don't even need to time it.
I just have to hold it.
Okay, that's way easier.
Wonder how you can break that glass door thing.
I don't know.
Hmm.
And then also here.
Like, what are these?
They're shining, so they must mean something.
Something.
But I do not know what.
Hmm.
Okay.
We continue onwards.
There was also another place that I walked into.
I probably should go back and check it out.
Biggest Lego set I ever built was a 4,000 piece Technic bucket.
Oh.
Mine!
No, this is not.
Wait, there was another place that I saw.
Oh, there's more here.
Yes.
You know what?
I'm gonna break all this stuff too.
Yes, break, break, break, break!
Give me something to break!
Sorry, Indy.
Indy, please move.
Where was it?
Dig those pieces up with the shovel.
What pieces?
Wait, so since I put these together, do I just break them again?
No, it won't let me.
That'd be funny, though.
There was a room that I went through.
Am I crazy?
Under the monkey.
Oh, wait.
I went in here.
That's right.
Yes.
I did.
Okay.
Oh, this is where I came from.
I'm all lost.
I'm all backwards.
Yeah, I was the star.
Okay.
Onwards!
Yes, everything's fine.
Yes.
No.
Nothing bad here.
Yes.
Only small characters can fit through hatches.
Godzilla.
I'm like walking on top of things just destroying, crashing them.
Like I
guess everybody doesn't care if I'm beating up their stuff.
I hear a camel.
Oh gosh.
The camel's kind of frightening.
Are you guys attacking me, or what's going on?
Oh, someone was having a nice dinner here.
Oh, Marianne, you handle that, and I'll take care of...
Oh, never mind, you shot me.
Oh my god, the camel's attack!
Let me grab that.
Oh, I gave him a nookie.
Before I literally destroyed his body.
The brutal It's kind of, you know Oh, he's cute Oh, he's cute Oh, oh, he's a Oh, son of a The money
The money Okay, so that can be pushed Got it Son of a brick Oh, my gosh The characters in this game really don't let up.
It's kind of insane.
Like, you get...
You know me, I like to take my time and explore and... But they're like, no.
You're gonna... You're gonna keep going.
Okay, I get it.
Oh.
Guys?
Game?
Are we okay?
Maybe that's what the adaptive difficulty is for.
Maybe.
Okay.
That was kind of spooky, huh?
I
just want to keep running around and destroying things and taking money.
I want to become big adventurer mode.
Oh my god, shut up, camel.
Oh,
I'm shooting.
Got his butt.
Oh, this is explosive, but I don't think I have anything that could explode.
Should I see anything?
No, I don't think so.
Let's try the other side.
Oh, wait, wait.
Hmm.
Dropped?
Oh, well.
Oh, wait.
I think I wonder if Marian...
Ah, it's fine.
Let's just keep going because they keep spawning.
Oh, wait.
We need to get rid of that thing first.
Wait, can we?
Can we get rid of it?
Hmm.
Serious.
You can pull, too?
Oh, I can.
Oh, I didn't realize.
Okay.
Nice.
Look at these little Lego pieces.
How fun.
Ah!
I have a sword!
Very good.
They're like, you want to throw this?
You want to get rid of this thing?
No, I like it.
It's my sword.
Ah!
Marion, don't turn your back on me.
These guys, we're in here waiting for an ambush.
Lore, accurate.
Just like the movie.
It's like when you're in a game and someone picks up like a wrench, like a horror game, and you're like, oh, this would be incredibly useful to keep around for...
Oh, I knew that was going to happen.
This is incredibly useful to hold up, have on hand.
And then the protagonist is like, I used it on this one door.
We're zigzagging.
Click every piece of loot.
Um, hello?
Oh, it's a monkey with dynamite.
All right, we'll just hide that there.
Hello?
Do we do need that?
Oh, oh.
Oh, he gave it to me lit.
Oh.
Wait, come on.
Oh no, my sword!
Oh,
I think we might want to do Marion.
She's so much more nimble.
And up!
Ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha.
What is...
What are we pulling down anyway?
Oh.
What was the point of that?
Aww, see this is relaxing and peaceful.
This is nice.
Oh wow, what of you?
Wow, there's so much money up here.
Oh, this is so relaxing.
Mmm.
Oh, barbecue!
I think you were supposed to do that before throwing the banana.
Oh yeah, it totally did work.
That's funny.
What's Vinky grilling?
Unlimited money.
I'm grilling nothing.
There'll be like...
It'll be like five.
people in chat that understands this.
What's Minky Grilling?
Can I destroy this too?
Nah.
Oh, let's go over...
I think we have to go over there, so what's down here?
I see.
Okay.
Easy does it?
Yes.
Oh my god, that's our first one that's kind of crazy haven't been very good at finding them huh
is that an old reference or just search what's dylan grilling and you'll you'll see the video what's dylan grilling
and i know i need to push this i'm grabbing all the money first or do i push this Yes.
Oh, what's this doing?
Oh, it's a...
It's a golf ball!
Cute.
Oh, this looks...
I hope we don't get ambushed in here.
It'll be very annoying.
Oh, yeah, yeah!
Oh, true adventurer!
That's me!
Oh, to me, I have a real adventure.
Wait.
You try.
Oh.
Hmm.
Wait.
Maybe he...
No?
No construction without destruction.
I'm gonna...
I'm going to destroy everything that they've put in their heart.
Work?
Oh my god!
Woo!
Everything that they've built so far, I'm destroying.
Indy!
Silver things like that need to be exploded.
I have nothing to explode.
No way to explode it!
Take that!
Give me.
Give me what I desire.
You think I can make this jump on the right?
Yeah, I thought so.
Often a free play.
I'm guessing in free play, you can bring whatever characters along that you want.
She's so nimble.
She's so graceful.
She's so hot and sexy and beautiful.
Her name is Minto!
Oh yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah, that's what everybody's thinking.
We don't have, oh wait, he's gonna give us the wrench.
Oh, Indy, you do your thing.
Okay!
Gosh.
What is this for?
Maybe over here?
Something?
Hmm.
Mysterious.
What's it for?
I like how you can...
Oh, oh, there we go.
Ah!
Oh my gosh.
Destroy everything!
I'm learning.
Okay, nice.
It's for this.
Okay, why does everything explode?
Oh.
Banana.
Oh, I see the other piece up top.
Thank you.
In order to create, you first must destroy.
Ah, there it is.
Okay, nice.
Okay, now we can build.
Do it.
Oh yeah, nope, do it.
Build.
Do what is in your blood.
I wasn't quite sure what we were building at first.
Oh, how cute!
Alright, I guess we continue onwards.
Can't wait to buy my $300 Lego Minto mini thing.
Oh, hello.
Yeah.
Take you out.
I'm gonna take you out.
Anybody else?
That's what I thought.
Um.
Yeah.
It's all dramatic for no reason.
Okay, now we can destroy... Oh, no, no, no.
Don't use your... Don't use your gun, Indy.
Don't waste the bullets.
Where are we going?
I guess we're gonna go kill some guys.
Oh.
Which I just did.
And then the music is happy again.
We kill.
And then music is happy.
Oh, and we kill.
And we kill.
And music.
Oh, no, not yet.
Oh, there's so many guys.
Wow, there's so many men!
Okay, Marion.
Holy cow!
Can I have...
Oh my gosh.
Can I have his hat?
I can.
No, no, no.
The hat.
Yes.
Oh,
my!
Hey!
Hey, hey!
Disguise.
She's crazy.
Wait.
I want to go...
Wait, can I go back?
It's quite far, but I want to like...
Oh my god, there's so many guys!
Holy moly, there's so many guys.
Remember how there was like the little... there was like a spot where um...
You could fool the guards.
Kind of want to get that.
Well, this is an explodey.
Oh, interesting.
Oh wait!
Oh here, maybe?
Hello!
Oh, yes, yes, yes!
I'm gonna fool him!
Hello!
What are you gonna get me?
Oh.
I don't think we fooled them.
Wait, we opened...
Wait, but then they...
But then they immediately knew that we were...
Wait.
Oh.
Wait, hi.
Wait, uh-huh.
How?
Why'd they let me in then?
Oh my gosh!
Well, I took them out too.
It's a mutual thing.
She doesn't have the hat.
Wait, does she act?
Wait.
Does she need to grab a hat?
Um...
Can I go in?
I gotta press Y.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, yes.
Oh, no, I should not have been given this much power.
Oh, yes.
Oops.
Oh, no.
Wait.
Oh, no, no, no.
Oh, no, no.
Oh, no.
Oops.
Wait, but there was so much stuff over here.
I still want to get money.
I have so much money.
Okay, I need to stop being greedy.
I need to stop being greedy.
Okay, where's my car?
Okay, here we go.
Alright.
Oh, nope.
Nope.
We're driving.
Let the lady drive.
Can I smash this?
Nope.
Hmm.
What else can I smash?
Not that.
It's okay, Indy can run.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right, here we go.
To the other side.
Here we go.
We're going to smash through their barricade.
This one right here.
Yeah!
Oh, a bike.
You can hit a ramp or...
Oh, wait!
Wait!
Oh, it's the scene, it's the famous scene!
Hello, my friend!
I think you're my friend, I can't actually tell who anybody is.
Behind?
Miriam!
Oh my gosh, how could she get kidnapped?
Aw, we just killed her.
He's so...
He's just so oblivious.
He's just like me, for real, for real.
We got Desert Innie.
Indie, Indie, Indie, Indie.
Howdy there, pretty lady.
How's the adventuring going?
I'm having fun.
I got one thing.
What else was there?
Oh, there were other characters to unlock.
Let's see.
Yeah, he's like a belly button.
Any belly button.
Oh, hi, Marion.
I think I'm done with the disguises for now.
We'll turn these off.
I have not seen what fertilizer is or secret characters are.
Or beep beep.
Yeah.
Oh, mysterious.
But let's buy some stuff.
Let's just buy everybody.
Bet I can at least.
Oh.
Add some more characters and free play.
Should we try a free play?
Let's go try one.
Since I have stuff unlocked, you know?
Oh, look, there's more people walking around.
So cute.
Let's try a free play of like...
Let's do like...
Two.
Oh, I can be anybody.
I can be this guy.
I can be...
Oh, I can be a patty!
Yes.
Wait, why are there so many people?
It's just the same level again.
Wait, am I going to be fighting him again?
I could be...
I could be Santa Claus!
I'm Santa!
What does Santa do?
What's special about him?
Oh my god, Santa destroy!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
moves do you get still do you get um what's it called goal like do you get to keep the money and free play oh even she gets to change
too bad we only have one lady yes oh oh it's i forgot about this oh you wouldn't you wouldn't beat up santa oh my god santa Santa Claus!
Santa's beefy.
Wait.
Does this guy never die?
Doesn't seem like it.
That's kind of awesome.
Yeah!
Ah!
Oops.
Yeah!
We're done.
God doesn't die.
It's so strong.
Wait, Santa.
Santa, what if you became a guy with a shovel?
Who has a shovel?
Wait, he has that other guy has a book.
What is this anyway?
Snowmobile.
Okay.
Oh, sorry, my bad.
And I'm going to ride it.
No.
Wait, why is it still shiny here?
What do you got?
Oh, we gotta dig up the rest.
Okay.
Oh, there's so much to dig up.
Does Santa...
Oh, my bad.
Okay, cover me.
Does Santa die?
Cover me.
Monk!
Everything's good.
Cover me, cover me.
I forget that they can't kill.
Oh my gosh, what is happening here?
Oh.
Woo!
That was cute.
Okay, I'm good here.
Um, I can say without saving, it's okay.
We didn't make much progress.
That was cute.
I understand now.
Wait, so we can unlock so many people.
Now, wait, I'm not even indie.
I'm not even indie.
Let's do chapter 4.
Wait, is there anything after 4?
There has to be.
Right.
They just haven't shown up yet?
Yeah.
There's six per movie.
Okay, okay, okay.
Let's get through, let's get through this movie and then we'll call it.
Still quite a bit left though.
As long as I don't like mess around too much, I think I'll be good.
I'm working, I'm working!
We didn't get to see the monkey die.
Yes, yeah, yes.
Mm-hmm, I am, yes.
Oh, snakes!
Oh!
Rude!
Oh, they're so cute, though.
This little Lego snakes.
Oh, my gosh, he's so cute!
The Well of Souls.
Some characters have phobias and will panic.
He'll find a way to clear a path.
Remember, small creatures will...
What?
What did he say?
Small creatures will avoid fire.
He's spooked.
He's like, no!
Oh, good.
This is the...
What's it called?
The book for translation.
What do you do?
Don't...
Don't follow me, Indy.
Don't follow me.
Don't do that, Indy.
I thought it would...
I thought they would be scared of me.
Nice.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
What's this do?
Oh!
Oh, shoot.
You touch one snake one time and you automatically are done so.
We're gonna build a fire!
Just like real life.
Yeah, exactly.
Take it.
And... nice.
Oh!
Okay, indeed there's like...
Wait, this is... this has a certain... Yeah, this has a time limit.
Do I get another one?
Oh no.
Oh yes I do!
Okay, oh yeah!
Alright, move over snakes.
Move over.
Was there anything over here?
Move over snakes!
I don't want to die.
Ah!
I know there's a door button.
I'm exploring!
Okay.
Anyway.
Get the other one, Indy.
No money.
It's okay.
Woo!
Watch out!
Oh!
Oh, I didn't see the one on the side!
Oh my goodness.
Be careful, everybody.
You know, I don't think I would cut it out really as an archaeologist.
Not an indie era, I think, maybe.
I think I wouldn't survive.
Did I pick that up?
How do we do this?
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Maybe this?
No?
Just kidding.
These are to be destroyed.
Not much is to be saved, huh?
The Laura Croft type.
I don't know, man.
Oh, I can just destroy the spike.
Lego, Lego!
Yeah, Lego!
Yeah!
Andy, I'm gonna need you to work.
Oh.
So cute.
You need a book.
Yeah, I have it.
I have it.
What's it say?
Oh.
Well, I have...
Wait, Indy, you still have...
Yeah, Indy has it.
It says...
Follow the sequence...
Wait, can you do it again?
Wait.
Easy peasy?
Minto would trigger all the traps.
live well i am a ghost for a reason maybe let me tell you that this game's co-op caused some sibling rivalry in my household yeah i believe it i like how all the fire has
oh oh you see that two little things stick out let's see is there anything we can do here to give over there.
I'm not sure.
I need a small character.
Okay, that's what I thought.
That's a little passageway had something to do with it.
Fancy.
Wow, there's so much in here.
Fancy, schmancy.
Let's see what's up here first.
Push me over!
Yes!
Good job!
Wait, you didn't finish the job.
There we go.
Oh.
Okay.
I guess that works.
Push me over!
Oh, good job, Indy.
Indeed!
Why did you do that?
Why did you do that, you dummy dumb?
You stupid head?
Why did you do that?
Indiana Jones.
Did you not see the puzzle that we were working on together?
It's a lot going on in here, huh?
Okay, let's just...
I feel like I'm a kid at an amusement park where I'm just like...
I'm...
Picking up everything and touching everything and pushing everything and pulling.
and everything.
I'm just getting into trouble.
Oh, let's see that diamond.
Okay, wait.
What's on the other side?
We can check.
Oh!
Oh, that's not good.
Wait.
Oh.
Yeah, beat them up.
Beat up those guys?
There's only like five of them.
of them.
It's fine.
Cool.
Right up spiders.
Destroy, destroy, battle!
Oh, there's more of them.
The music is so good.
Oh, sorry, Indy.
I think I'm beating you up.
I was...
Oh, a head.
It goes to you.
Uh-oh.
What's that sound?
Oh, there's another guy.
I think he's dead now.
Okay, Indy.
Do you remember the problem, the puzzle that we were just working on?
You remember that?
Okay, Indiana Jones.
You're gonna do that puzzle, and you're gonna be so great at it, okay?
All right.
You're gonna go up here.
And then, you're gonna go, like, here.
And then, that thing, how did that thing work before?
Why did it move on its own before?
We don't know.
Wait, there's a thing here.
He is a silly guy.
He's a really silly man.
We don't fault him for that.
Can I get...
No.
And I see that exploding guy, too.
Wait, wait, wait.
Actually, how does this work?
How am I supposed to get to the other side?
Maybe Indy knew that it was a stupid idea.
He was saving me the embarrassment.
Can I get some TNT?
Oh, wait!
Oh, I see, I see!
Oh, thank you guys.
I was wondering how I could attach to that.
Okay, so then if I have him...
That's right, I was like, I did move this over.
I'm not dumb.
Like, I moved this over for a reason.
Oh, oh!
Okay.
Ah, that's why!
Okay, okay, okay.
I was like, wait a second.
I knew I was missing a step.
Okay, we're fine now.
Everything's good.
Good job.
Drigos!
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you!
We're the 20 gift!
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, now we're back in business.
Yeah, Indy just ran off that one time.
Yeah, yeah, exactly!
I was like, wait.
I thought it was me.
It was not me.
Wait.
This needs to go...
Well, this needs to go...
here on here oh now we have two of them and we have lots of money to grab he's like you think I blend in you think anybody will notice wait it's fun fight there we go just updated the Lego Minto ghost cafe to include Indiana Jones his classic jungle cruiser and the Skelly Butler you made Thank you!
Can't wait to see.
Now we take our money, and now we do this.
There we go.
No!
Oh!
I'm not nimble enough.
I'm not a nimble lady.
Ah!
Dang it.
Grab it.
I'm not nimble enough of a lady.
Double jump?
There is no double jump, you guys.
Maybe he has one.
Let's see.
You just did it.
Does this look like a double jump to you?
Jump backwards.
Oh.
Oops.
Jump backwards.
Let's try.
I might be a genius.
Alright, let's go.
Like how he keeps scratching his head.
Okay.
We got a lot going on in here too.
Good thing we have a shovel!
And we got a book.
Oh, okay, this again.
Alright, here we go.
Breed.
Middle down, up.
Middle, down, up, right.
Ha ha ha ha!
I am smarter than a fifth grader.
Oh wait, do I need Indy for this?
Oh, dang it.
Okay, no.
I should be able to grab it.
Let's do it.
Let's try Indy.
Why is he so cool and why is he...
There we go.
Okay, yeah, we do need Indy.
He grabs it with one hand.
You're smarter than me?
Are you a fifth grader?
Oh.
Oh,
it's making me want to ride Indiana Jones ride.
Where does this go?
Is that ice cream?
I kind of wish.
Where does this go?
I'll put it here for now.
Oh, maybe it goes on there.
Yes.
Hail?
Yes, I see it.
Oh,
that's just to install it.
Okay, just kidding.
You dig.
Thank you.
No, not yet.
Hold on, there's more to destroy and more to loot.
Take all this money.
Put it towards retirement.
Ha!
Did I get everything in here?
Hmm.
Wait.
What's back there?
How mysterious?
It looks like something.
Maybe I can't get it.
All right.
Wow!
Ooh!
Indy, this is your show.
The Ark of the Covenant.
I sure hope we're not ambushed here.
I sure hope I'm not left here to die.
Ah!
Oh, wow.
Goodbye.
Okay, well, um, now we have a nimble lady.
Let's go Nimble lady Oh, I think Indy needed to be on that one Okay, lady Let's go Alright, now hold on tight Like, don't even let go a little bit
Okay, cool I think that worked
You're okay Okay You're okay, little baby.
You're okay.
I don't think there were any coins over on this side anyway, so it's a good thing I didn't try and explore.
Hmm.
Ah.
Ah!
Oopsie.
You remind me of the spider queen from the grim adventures of Billy and Mandy every time you do your little discovery hum.
Discovery hum.
Wait, what do I do?
Wait.
How do I sound?
I'm scared.
Indy, move out of the way.
Yes.
I'm too good.
Your Honor.
She's a gamer.
I'm a nimble lady.
What's my discovery, hum?
What do I go?
What do I say?
Like that?
Sorry, you missed Indy adjusting his hat.
When I open secret paths, I don't know what sound I make.
I just make it.
Okay, hold on.
Oh!
There's many ways to go here.
I'm a true... scared me.
Holy cow.
Sorry, buddy.
Just game?
I'm gaming.
I'm gaming!
the mod?
Yeah, clearly I must.
No, pull it.
Okay.
Wait, which way do we go?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
There was so much more.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, okay.
Oh, oh, I think I missed my cue.
Please don't kill me.
Okay, we're fine.
Don't be gaming.
Oh.
Why would you jinx me like that?
Now why would you do that to me?
I need to be...
What?
Why'd she let go?
Wait, actually, why'd she let go?
I'm not pushing anything.
Wait, I wasn't pushing...
Oh, the brick on the wall!
Oh, I see, I see.
Oh, oh!
Oops.
Okay, we can do this.
I need you to use your arms.
Oh, ah, gosh!
Maybe I can.
Do you guys think?
Jump left and right, but look up.
Oh!
Dude.
Trying to look up.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, this is kind of insane.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Oh, no!
Oh, you can't stay on it.
even two seconds!
How fast do you have to be?
Oh my gosh.
Oh, I got it though.
Okay, okay, I got it.
First try.
First try, let's go.
I want to be greedy, but I won't.
Now we continue onward now that I got what I wanted.
Oh, she's a gamer.
You know it.
Okay, it needs to go into that corner.
I see.
All right, Indy, you could move out of the way, please.
Okay.
Oh, I see why.
Oh!
I should just punch the hell out of that snake.
Have you kissed her yet?
Yes, I have.
I'll do it again, though.
I'm surprised she doesn't slap me.
She just lets it happen.
Maybe she likes me.
You guys, do you think she likes me?
Do you think she likes me?
Indy's got that Riz, man.
Oh,
I have the shovel.
Nah, that's crazy.
Yeah, there's no way.
There's, like, no stinking way.
Oh, what?
Only one person can have something at a time?
There we go.
Okay, and you put it in.
Get a commission of my OC cosplaying you.
Tuber and can't cosplay, IRL.
Of course!
Um...
Yeah.
I don't see why not.
Uh, I think, uh...
People pretty much...
I'm pretty much okay with...
Like, you know...
Any kind of fan art.
UAA!
Punch it.
Uh...
Aha!
Now no more snakes will come down.
Punch it.
Okay, we got one.
It said one out of three.
Where do I jump, though?
Oh, wait.
I guess I need to do this, too, huh?
I completely forgot that I put this together.
Alright.
Okay.
I'm a nimble lady.
Oh.
There we go.
Okay.
Nimble lady.
Oh.
Where'd it go?
Indy.
Just punch it.
Just punch it, Indy.
Okay.
Whoa.
Oh.
Was that there the whole time?
Ow!
John!
Sorry.
That's actually you for...
That's for you being dumb.
Indiana Jones.
Okay.
Saw a snake over here?
Or maybe it didn't.
Ask Marion out and make a Shia LaBuff together.
Hey, hey, hi!
Oh my gosh, nah, well, thank you so much for the...
What the heck?
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you so much, thank you.
Hoi!
Hoa!
Come on, we can do it.
Please!
Oh, maybe I needed to jump when it was still open!
Okay.
I missed my chance.
How, though, can I get the thing up there?
Wait, I think this is probably trapped, huh?
Yeah.
Better to ask for permission first.
Of course!
Thank you for asking.
Wow.
Okay.
I guess we just continue onwards then.
Are there gonna be mummies in here?
Fire hurt.
Not good.
Fire bad.
I'm destroying precious artifacts!
Ah!
Oh my gosh.
Got me good.
Oh, wow!
Wait, I'm stuck.
I'm stuck.
No, no, no, no.
Oh my gosh.
I thought I was gonna be stuck in a loop for real.
I was scared.
I was scared that I wouldn't be stuck in a death loop.
Oh my gosh.
He looks like a guy that's walking out, you know?
But when he comes out is so cute.
I forgot we can destroy spikes.
I think I got rid of it.
Yeah.
Destroy everything.
Yeah, you spikes don't bother me.
Nerdy laundry.
Thank you so much for the five.
Gifted Thacker.
I think it's Mint's first Lego game.
It is.
Well, my first, like, IP Lego game.
Yeah.
I don't think I could...
Oh.
Oops.
I don't think I can count Lego Island, probably.
Pop up.
Yeah.
Pop it.
Oh.
Not me.
Don't pop me.
Yeah, there we go.
Okay, now we don't have to worry about it anymore.
Whoa!
Oh.
Okay, now we don't have to worry about it anymore.
Sam Barney, thank you so much for the vibe, good to thank you!
Ooh.
What is...
What is this?
Can I just punch through here?
Oh.
Very carefully?
Oh, no.
I'd say Lego Island counts.
You think so?
You still got...
Oh, he doesn't have the book anymore.
There's gotta be one around here somewhere.
Right?
Probably.
If you stand on it, do they eventually come back up?
Yes.
Come
on!
Lucky.
Whoa!
No, don't pick it up.
Can't punch everything.
Well, why not, huh?
Why not?
What is this thing?
I'm ready to punch the world.
Grab that and grab that and grab that.
that and grab that and jump.
But I don't have a book!
Am I doing all this for nothing?
Indy, you shall have your book.
You shall have your book.
For what?
What was this for?
Meow meow meow meow meow meow.
Mew, meew, meew, meew.
Mew, meew, meew, meew, meew, meew, meew.
Adventure?
I get a cell.
Oh.
Hoah!
Oh, keep going up.
Hello.
Nice.
Wait, how the hell did you get over here?
Did Deanna Jones?
What?
How did you get over here?
How did he do that?
I thought...
He's just that good.
Archaeologist powers.
Oh.
Okay, interesting.
That does a thing.
Can he make this?
Oh, he can!
Okay.
That works.
That wasn't the intention, but...
Double jumped.
Obviously.
Yeah, yeah, he double jumped.
I knew that guy had it in him.
I knew he had it in him the whole time!
Oh.
No, no.
Now put it in.
There we go.
Okay.
The shovel.
I know.
It's so sad.
We lose it.
Oh my god.
Marion, I need you to do anything.
Oh, I died.
Marion, this is all up to you.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Um.
Oh, maybe I throw fire at it.
Oops.
It would help to hit it.
Okay.
Can I have more fire?
There he is.
Ouch!
Indy, I need you to pull your weight, buddy.
Oh, dang it.
I'm grabbing my money.
Oh.
Pick that up.
Oh, oh my gosh.
I wish I could dodge, for real.
He's dead!
Nina Jones did nothing?
The hell.
I just want to say that right now.
He let the lady do the entire job.
He did absolutely nothing.
Wait.
Can you try that again?
How am I supposed to reach that?
Classic Indy.
Is it?
Not really his style.
Maybe we push in.
Oh.
I didn't know this was pushing out of the...
It's because he's scared of snakes.
I know.
My hat.
Ah!
Woo!
He doesn't look the same without his hat, you know?
He's got to have the hat on.
Oh,
seven loot.
I had no idea that was the end of it.
We didn't get much treasure this time, guys.
That's okay, though.
I still feel stinking rich.
I still feel pretty rich.
I'm not gonna lie.
Let's continue the story.
Okay, this should be the last...
Wait.
Or there's two more.
Oh!
How'd you find us?
This just feels like I'm playing Minecraft.
Bozo.
Oh my gosh, I just got here!
Get his butt.
Nice.
I'll let the pretty lady do the job.
Oh my gosh.
Don't kill me.
She knocks him out?
I take him out.
Wow!
Okay, we should be safe for two seconds because this game is crazy aggressive with a...
Oh, they give us all sorts of supplies.
With respawning enemies and such.
Power of friendship.
Is this friendship?
I think she's in Rabu with me, actually.
Oh.
I need this.
And then we dig.
I think she's in rubble with me.
Wait, why am I about to lose the wrench?
I don't need that.
Are we sure?
Okay, game.
You're a little funny.
I don't really understand you sometimes.
Oh.
Come on, pretty lady.
Easier?
Much easier?
What is this deal?
Where does this go?
What do we do with this?
What is this anyway, also?
Uh-oh.
What is it?
Let's take this, um...
On here?
I thought it would go on the shining platform, but clearly not.
I'm just walking around now.
Directionless, I fear.
Yeah.
Leave me alone.
Doing my job.
Oh, see, we do need the wrench.
Do you guys see it?
Oh my gosh, there's so much gold.
That guy's waiting for us up there.
Cute!
Oh.
Dang it.
I messed it all up.
Okay, so this goes...
I'm looking for like arrows and I'm not seeing anything.
Okay, hold on.
It doesn't go here?
Okay.
Oh, this is another spot to dig up.
Hiding in barrels.
Just a barrel.
There's so much going on in here.
Okay.
Oh, that was some good cash.
Let's go.
Okay.
Let's get over here.
Let's take all of this.
Let's get some money, baby.
Okay.
All right.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay.
Hmm.
Oh, I see here.
Okay, okay.
All right, that's one.
I can't tell if this is, like, to progress or not.
Come here.
Alrighty.
Any items you drop, respawn at their...
Oh, come on.
original locations to stop them getting stuck in walls, etc.
Oh, that's handy.
I forgot we can destroy all these, too.
Should have done it when I had the chance.
Yeah, yeah, destroy, destroy.
Marion, stay out of my way.
Wait, what are these for, though?
I can't tell at all.
What the crates are for...
We have two of them.
Oh, we got another barrel.
Nice.
The crane.
Oh, is it right there?
Was the thing that it was right next to?
Are you kidding?
Are you telling me I've brought this other one all the way over here for nothing?
Oopsie.
Whoopsie.
Yes.
My point says...
Nice.
All right.
Let's grab...
Wait, where did I put it?
Oh, down here, here.
It's fine.
It's not that far along.
Mint the flirt.
What can I say if I see a pretty lady in front of me?
to smooth your face.
I'm sure we can all relate, huh?
At least most of us?
I'm sure many of us can relate.
Okay, now we gotta power this thing, huh?
Okay.
Oh, oops.
Late.
Okay, okay.
Okay, let's, uh, there we go.
Aha!
Okay, okay.
What do I do?
Like,
Okay, okay.
I guess that's it?
Why is it so intense right now?
All of a sudden.
I wonder if we can get to the other side.
Like, there's something flashing over there.
Will it hurt me?
No?
Hmm.
I wonder if I picked this up with me on it.
Whatever.
Oh my gosh, my depth perception.
You guys, I really thought I had that.
I really thought I had that.
Okay, shadow.
Yes.
Follow where my shadow is on the ground.
Some puzzles can only be completed by pressing Y to control another character.
Oh, oh no!
We don't have another thing!
Gosh, there's so much stuff in here.
There's like a crazy amount of stuff in here.
Oh, let's get a wrench.
I'm remembering.
I saw one...
Uh...
Here?
Yes.
Oh!
Hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm.
And then this does...
Oh!
Ooh!
Exciting.
Am I too fat?
Oh, it broke!
Again?
Wait.
Okay.
I guess that's all I needed.
Hmm.
Mm-hmm.
Okay, but why?
Um...
I don't know.
Alright, so where would the last track piece be then?
Unless I need to push this into that hole.
Oh yeah.
Wait, can we go in here?
Or is it for a small character?
Yes, only small character.
Oh!
But, ah, but, but, but, but, okay, okay.
Got it, got it.
I understood the assignment.
I understood.
Now we have track.
Now we gotta go do all this again.
Some of these, I'm just like, oh my gosh.
How do I...
Get in there.
Oh my gosh.
Depth perception.
Please.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
My depth perception is so bad, everybody.
Okay.
I keep looking at my shadow and it just...
It doesn't do anything for me.
Alright, Indy.
Stop!
We're building?
Oh no, we need to dig.
I forgot the shovel.
Tip for depth perception, look at where your shadow is cast.
Yeah, I said that earlier that I try to do that and I still have trouble.
It's just one of my things, please, you guys.
It's just one of those things.
I can't help it.
I try.
I really do.
Okay.
Ender!
Uh-oh.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Don't leave.
Okay.
We're fine.
Oh, my gosh.
She almost fell off.
Okay.
Okay, and dig!
I have to go back.
I actually...
Does she even need the ladder?
I wonder.
Probably not.
I think she could probably jump high enough to get that.
Wait.
Don't do it.
Marion?
Marion.
You're lucky.
You're beautiful.
Oh.
One moment, please.
I found a shortcut.
Oh yeah, yeah, you're right, you're right.
Okay.
No, please.
Oh no, no, stop.
No, stop it, stop it, please.
No, stop.
Okay, there we go.
All right, we're fine, we're fine.
All right, and there's a guy up here with a gun who's ready to kill us.
Take us down.
Cool.
One hit wonder.
Our little Lego man.
Woohoo!
Oh, we're running?
What are we running for?
What are we going so fast for?
Yeah, explode!
Yeah!
Explode!
Explode, yeah!
Blood sport.
Oh gosh, there's a lot of guys here.
Oh, that was a guy with a grenade.
Okay, wait, I can get the hat.
Nice.
They'll never know.
Wait, I lost my hair.
I lost my hair.
Okay.
Very good.
But we probably need that to get inside, huh?
We need to fool them because they're stupid dummies.
Is this what I'm hearing?
Hit a ramp or press B when riding motorbikes.
Whoa!
Where's a ramp at?
Oh,
you jerk.
Indy,
take them out!
Okay, very good.
Good job, team.
Oh, I'm stuck in here for some reason.
Okay, yeah, I got him.
Indy, get their hat.
Indy, get the hat.
Yeah, you put it on too.
Okay, now we're both in disguise.
Ah, we lost our disguises!
I think at one point, I did not even realize what I was pressing.
And I just kept switching between them.
This is my bad.
I'm so stupid.
Like that?
That's what I was doing.
I didn't even realize what I was what I was pressing.
Oh, Marion, don't stand in the way.
I was going like this trying to beat them up.
Is this one of those Areas where they just don't stop coming.
There's another bike.
We can both ride.
Ow, jaw.
Please.
I just want to, I want to explore a little.
They don't stop coming.
I wish I could grab the grenade, huh?
It'd be pretty nice.
Ouch.
I lost my hat.
You glorious!
Simpleton!
Yeah!
Nice.
Wait.
Some
dumb stupid head.
that up.
Surely they'll stop eventually, huh?
Alright, I think we just need to move onwards.
Oh my gosh, I think we just need to move onwards.
Oh, Indy, you lost your heart!
Okay, or?
They're gone?
I don't think so.
Nope.
Let's go.
Ah!
Oh!
Okay, that wasn't...
That didn't go as I planned.
Okay, neither did that.
How do I get off the bike?
Wait, how do I get off the bike?
Get off the bike.
There we go.
Okay, let's build this, whatever it is.
It's not why.
Why is not to get off the bike, in case you were curious.
It's definitely not why.
Alright, that's one thing.
What's this?
Ooh, okay.
I'm gonna beat up everything in your park!
I'm gonna destroy your tables!
You'll never eat again!
Yeah!
You'll never sit down for a nice meal!
You'll never...
Oh, sorry, Indy.
I thought you were them.
Yeah, it's why to get on, but you have to jump to get off.
They'll never enjoy peace.
They'll never have peace again.
Wait, what's this for?
Where does this go?
Oh, hello.
I just jumped off and...
Okay, silly.
Other way.
This way?
Yeah, they're gonna starve!
They're gonna starve!
Oh my god, I dig that up too.
Hmm.
Let's see if...
Minecraft.
They will never have another drink of water again!
It's a ladder piece.
Like the ladder...
Oh.
Wait.
Oh my gosh, so close.
Okay.
Cool.
Okay, now I'm turning.
Well, okay.
Now stop.
Alright.
Now jump.
And jump.
She's a platforming god.
Wait, I don't have another piece, though.
I don't have the last one that we need.
Oh, wait.
It's a lever.
Just kidding.
Yippee!
Okay.
Oh, right, what's this?
I got a gun.
I got a bigger gun.
Was it the ladder?
Not this ladder, right?
Ladder piece.
Piece to what ladder?
Ew.
There's that over there, that green thing.
Oh, wait, it is over here.
I see it.
So nostalgic.
Where is it?
And then I guess I get this one too.
Grab it?
Okay.
I want to become a grand adventurer or I need to take more money.
Alright.
So let's beat things up and take more money.
Yeah!
Oh, uh, jump?
Is it the other side?
Wait.
Do I not know how to use a ladder?
Oh, there we go.
Like, hello?
How do I open this up?
Hmm.
We gotta explode it, I think.
Also, look at this.
This explodes too.
I don't think we have any explodies, though.
maybe over over here but I'm a maybe guys have stopped spawning let's check it out
oh my bad oh no they have not okay let's leave
okay okay oh sorry oh
Okay, we ignore that area?
It sucks.
Wait, but what's this way?
Oh.
How do I get in here?
To their little relaxation area.
Oh, let's not.
Secret area.
Okay, I'm going to...
I'm gonna get on my bike and see you, Indy.
Oh.
Oh, wait, is this fight?
Ah!
Hold on, I was taking a sip!
Oh my gosh, we actually have to...
Oh!
Woo!
Oops.
What's over here?
What is this?
Is this to throw at him?
Oh, okay, just kidding.
What is this?
I don't have...
Fists are flying.
Yeah, absolutely.
Oh, wait, I think this goes...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, it does not go up here?
We'll leave it alone for now.
I like how he just stays within the circle.
He's like, what is it?
He's like a sea bear.
He can't leave.
Hold it and give him a punch?
Well, I tried to throw it at him, but I guess he can't really...
Wait, can I grab this and throw this at him?
From outside the circle.
How devilish would that be?
Hello?
Oh.
Okay.
This has got to be the key.
I
don't like that.
Wait, are there reinforcements?
Messed up!
Hey!
Oh my gosh, there's so many of them.
Stop shooting me!
I wish I could shoot this guy.
Okay.
All right, I have nothing to repair that.
I need more stuff to pick up, I guess.
Do I have anything to pick up?
He's bulletproof.
Nothing that moves.
Fire away, fire away.
Ring and chain.
Everything you're right.
I have no supplies.
Slow supplies.
Maybe in the truck.
Oh.
Just shooting.
Willy nilly.
Ah.
Huh?
Is there anything else to get him with?
Am I crazy?
Can you use the plane?
Oh, oh gosh.
I can...
Attempt.
It does not let me in it.
Oh, God.
The big water canister on the bottom right.
This?
I can't fix it, though.
I have no supply.
I don't have a wrench.
What about the tree?
Oh, wait.
Maybe this?
I can try.
Oh, nope.
Oh.
Wait, this goes to this up here!
Ouch!
No, that's my thing, please.
Stop punching us!
Okay, we're fine.
Everything is okay.
I remember there was a part over here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, up there.
Can you get- when I got in the plane, it hopped me right out.
Like, he sat in there for two seconds and then he jumped out.
No, no, no.
Oh, I can't do anything yet.
Is there anything else?
Oh, there's one.
Okay.
Got another one.
Gotta keep destroying.
Destroy to create.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, hey.
Let's see.
You!
No.
Where else?
You!
Hmm, over here.
Eew!
You would think that if this was one of them...
Oh wait, hold on, maybe you.
No.
Okay, never mind.
If it's buried there, I don't have any way of getting it out.
That's the issue.
Unless I can't explode.
I'm running out of options here.
Let's try to get in these.
They don't give me any tools.
It's definitely the plane.
You think so?
Let's see what's in here real quick.
Okay, not the...
Oh, wait.
There's one more tree.
Not the tree.
Oh.
Oh, I gotta run him over.
Maybe?
Marion, are you okay?
Um...
Uh...
Yeah, in the movie, you get him...
What?
Um...
Okay, wait, okay.
Do you hear it honking?
It's so funny.
Okay, hold on.
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
Please.
Wait!
No!
Oh!
Is that the last thing we needed?
Maybe.
I want to also beat up the other thing though.
Okay, cool.
Nice, okay, that's another one.
Marion, you can do the honors.
Oh, just kidding.
Okay, Indy, you can do the honors.
Oh, he's a little feast!
Oh, oh!
Oops.
Oh, no, there's more guys!
Oh, my gosh!
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, I need that heart.
Never mind.
Nucky!
Alright.
Now we do the plane.
Okay.
I'm understanding.
You would think that I could blow him up with the, you know.
With the, uh, plan, but...
I guess that...
Oh, sick moves, Marion.
That doesn't really work, clone.
I will do the honors this time.
Yes!
Little hand!
Oh, see, I wanted to kill him myself, but, oh, wow, decapitation.
I tried to get him with the propellers.
It was too difficult.
Your eyes, everybody, yeah, look away.
Oh, what's happening here?
Okay.
Oh, not good.
Indy, out of the way.
Indy, I'm gonna kill you.
I think
maybe I should be ND.
Oh!
We're fine.
Nah, maybe I won't be ND.
When?
Oh!
We can drive!
Okay, nice.
Interesting.
Okay, fine.
Wait, I'm gonna be...
Oh, oops.
I think I fell.
Where am I?
Oh, hello.
I like having a shovel to uh, you know, to bonk people with.
I think that's a lot of fun.
And we're driving, we're driving.
I'm accelerating.
How nice of them to just kind of like let us in, you know?
Who's that?
Wait, I'll take it!
Give it to me!
Yes!
That guy doesn't even...
That guy was just standing there.
He had no clue what was coming to him.
And drive the car.
Drive the car.
Somebody drive the car.
Somebody get in the car.
Indy, get in the car.
Treasure get!
We're accelerating.
There it is!
Yeah, come over here if you're so...
I think Indy died.
And I come over here if you're so tough.
I love the way they just stand there and smile like default Lego men.
You know?
Oops.
Oh.
I don't think I can make it.
Oh, yes I can.
Indy?
Indy, where'd you go?
Oh.
Alright, let's get in the car.
Let's drive this thing.
Get in the car, Shinji!
Ah,
run him off the road!
Uh-oh, nobody secured this thing.
Oh, oh!
Is that her bedroom wear?
Indy!
Indy, take a hint!
Lego Marion is horny!
Oh my god.
They can never catch a break, huh?
Indy!
Oh my gosh.
Guys, I'm actually so tired.
I forgot about that noise.
I want to beat this one, but I'm actually so...
I'm getting a headache, unfortunately.
Oh, well, I've had one since, like, a couple episodes ago.
It's been a long one.
Yeah.
I am pretty tired.
I didn't expect to feel so icky.
But I am having so much fun.
Wait, no, not the movie room.
Let's go buy some more people.
There we go.
Buy everybody.
Buy everyone.
Meow.
So close to greatness!
I really wanted to beat the first wine, but...
That's okay.
We next time can beat it, and then we can...
I'll actually know how this is, how it works a bit more so we can beat Temple of Doom as well.
Yes, yes, yes.
Oh, this has been a lot of fun.
I love Covenant of the Ark.
I can't wait to see how they do the opening of the Ark.
Like how the little spirits will work.
Tomorrow, I have a big, big announcement.
So, please be there.
Tell your friends.
Come see Minky's big announcement.
And, um, yeah.
Silly Lego version.
Silly Lego ghosts, maybe.
Dwargo, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Big, big announcement.
So.
I'm excited And I'm sleepy And I want to be rested For tomorrow Really thank you Hi for karaoke Karaoke, karaoke, karaoke Karaoke, karaoke Outsu Minto, Mina-sama Kiaomo, Arigato Howdy duty Tote-tote Tano Shikoto Um, uh, uh, I know, uh, uh, Choco, Arigato.
Now, well, Arigato.
I wish you all, uh, Root and Toot.
Uh, wonderful evening, or morning, whatever time zone it is for you, yeah, yeah, and Nanji Drew, is that you?
Bye-bye, Minto.
Arigato, Arigato Chu.
Thank you, everyone.
Thank you so much.
Have a good day.
Have a good night.
Have a good time, Zen.
And I'll see you when I see you.
Hopefully tomorrow.
Hopefully.
Takedo, thank you!
Sorry, I couldn't beat the first movie, but we'll beat it next time.
Thanks for the stream.
Thank you, thank you!
Sorry, it was so low energy, I feel.
It was just kind of...
But it was still a lot of fun.
O2!
Eat the lasso!
Bye bye!
Thank you everyone!
Thank you so much!
Bye bye bye bye bye bye bye!
Bye bye bye bye bye!
Bye bye bye!